you got to get on stage everywhere you
got iron you got it you got to do a
wedding you got to do a baby shower you
got to do a bar you got to do a
laundromat you got to do you got to do a
coffee shop you got to do everything you
got to do colleges you got to do a
college college cafeteria on top of a
table while people just want their
dinner and on some other people want to
watch the soap opera that's on the TV
behind you that's different now because
everybody has phones you got it you know
I mean you got it you got to do stand-up
in places where they're not expecting
you you got to do stand-up in places
where they don't want you to be mmm you
got a deuced and you got to learn how to
how to win people over you got to learn
how to make people go or who the [ __ ] is
this and by the end of it how do we not
hear about him before
[Music]
yeah in these exact seats I interviewed
Craig shoemaker and he gave us the most
epic groupie squirting story do you know
you familiar Craig shoemaker yeah it was
a lot he said it's the only time he'll
ever tell the story but it got I'm sure
so let's just let you know this show is
all just we started we started I'll do
the intro in a second okay but it's just
all comedy mastery so and even in
listening to your interviews it seemed
you're full of wisdom and it seems like
you're I would love to just extract as
much of that as possible
whatever yeah just go wherever you leave
me perfect all right so all right hot
breath podcast welcome back hot breath
verse I am your host comedian Joel Byers
this is the hot breath podcaster weekly
guide to comedy mastery today's guest is
not only a master of crowd work but he
is a master of the comedian mindset two
weeks into exploring an explosives
engineer degree he tries an open mic
next thing he knows he's hitchhiking
from Vancouver to Montreal and back and
then moving to New York with $1,000 to
his name stays in a hostel for four
months then books Conan now he's had
Comedy Central specials HBO specials
showtime specials this is a comedian who
has put his mind to something and has
achieved it so we're hoping that you
watching out there find this helpful in
developing your mindset to be persistent
as a comedian but if you do find this
helpful subscribe to our YouTube our
iTunes support us hopper at podcast.com
support our guest hit him up on all
social media let him know how helpful
this episode was and with that being
said Ian bagg welcome to the hot breath
verse body I shoulda wore pants were you
thinking that as soon as you watch it as
I watch it like he's wearing a suit not
wearing a suit my goodness it's it's my
2019 I've been wearing more suits
okay because I have a wife and I think
she's ready for me she's ready for you
to have a day job hit the next level
yeah she's ready oh my goodness she's
like you should be a lawyer not a
comedian do you find that like in comedy
it's kind of what you put out is what
you'll get back yeah yes what do you
have - I listen to a podcast called Gary
Vee I don't know if yes yes so and he
talks about and I don't know if we're
allowed to swear on this but he said
whatever you want he talks about you
basically you got a you got to get your
dick dragged in the dirt to get
someplace and I feel I feel you should
never expect anything mmm that's how I
feel you should just be doing stuff and
should never expect anything
what comedies are very personal it's a
personal experience as a personal
journey so what you do will not work for
me
mmm what your timeline will not be my
timeline we just have to do our thing so
if you love it you'll do it you won't
expect anything from it you'll just do
it because you get you get all the
pleasure from doing whatever show it is
no matter bar theater concert venue or
whatever you know you love it doesn't
matter so and if you don't it's a much
longer journey and probably you're a
much better better bitter bitter person
than a better person but you've been
doing it since 94 yeah about 94 yeah
about 94 yeah holy when I listen to you
get my intro I'm like oh I should be
much further than where I am that's all
I could think I just like oh man my
management and agents have a right to be
depressed we've done all that stuff and
none of us are millionaires as I tell
you all that then I'm like I should be
Rick be better not bitter and you're
like I've been doing this too long but
what is further along what do you mean
like what I don't know I don't I I have
a I have a theory in life be happy with
where you are but never satisfied hmm
so I don't know we're further along
should be may we should I be selling
more tickets in the comedy club that
might be further along for me like every
show should be sold out
every couple shows you know so that's
further along for me where somebody else
further along might be they needed a TV
show they need something less they
needed that so I don't know where
further along is but I should be there
it seems like you've almost just just
done action you've just put yourself
into situations and then whatever
happens happens it seems like you
haven't really you normally have a
specific game plan you just do and then
accept the outcome um I've also had the
theory that doesn't matter what you do
as long as you get a couple jokes out of
it it doesn't matter so whether it's
getting beaten up whether it's wrecking
a motorbike or whether it's you know as
long as you get a joke out of it who
cares so that's that's but that's who I
am that's not who you should be but
that's who I am
so yeah yeah so I just go do things like
when I moved to New York I just was a
little bit of it was a little bit of
want and a little bit of just being so
naive that I didn't know I should be a
twenty five twenty year old kid going
into New York by myself with a thousand
dollars Canadian in my pocket you know I
mean not even I didn't even I'm so I'm
so dumb I didn't even exchange it in
Canada I exchanged it in America and
they're just like what's this I mean
that's Canadian money yeah there's
something about that comedian mindset
because I've been doing a little nine
years mm-hmm the first time I do it was
the second semester senior year of
college mm-hmm and I as soon as I did it
I'm like that's it it I it is shift it's
heroin
yeah it's honestly heroin you're either
addicted or you're not yeah the guys
that can go I'm just taking a three-year
break I'm like no that's not how heroin
works you you ride it into the ground or
you're done right yeah yeah so like Don
Rickles said like comedians don't die a
retired they die yeah you know yeah
there's that guy that died on stage in
England a couple weeks ago oh I hear Ian
Ian I can't remember what is in
something his name was Ian but just walk
on right there oh yeah we're doing we're
doing this in a hotel yeah we're doing
news we had though when I just go on
through just going through okay all
right when I did
Craig's interview there were people over
there just sitting watching us we like
missed an audience watching you guys
talk dumb no I don't know he died the
guy the guy that died he died on stage
and it was amazing how many people were
just like that's how I want to go
onstage but whenever you read anything
there's been a couple guys that had
happened it takes people they probably
would have survived had they had their
incident anywhere else but because
they're on stage people just watch for
another 10 minutes thinking it's a bit
oh man so they oh they could have
revived him had they done something but
they didn't do anything because they
thought he was being funny um-hmm so
it's something about that mindset of
like I mean if it wasn't second semester
senior year I would have dropped out of
school but I was like I might as well
finish the drill now but I think like
Brian Regan quit like the week of
graduation and was just like no that's
it yeah what it what is it because
you've you've been in comedy so long
you've in New York you were around
people like Jim Gaffigan and Chris Rock
and Dave Chappelle and all these greats
everybody it was all oh it's what you
play to your level right so if you go in
at a certain level and suddenly around
all these guys that are strong your
level is going to get better sadly
they're gonna get worse hanging around
you because you play to your level so
they come down oh that's sad but you
just you know you have to you have to
just do you have to just keep doing all
the work it doesn't matter where you are
you should always want to keep moving
you never want to be that guy that is
the big fish in that town you want to
keep moving to the next level and you
know because that big fish has a
tendency to eat all the Guppies and then
suddenly end up on the shore not doing
anything you know I mean so you just
want to I I i went from Vancouver to New
York and then New York to LA to LA had I
did I need to move was I the big fish in
New York no I was I was I was a medium
sized fish with a lot of medium sized
fish and I moved to LA not because I
needed to a bigger space but because I
grew up in Canada and I found out that
it's warm all
time in Los Angeles and I can do what I
can do in Los Angeles that's what I
wanted to do but if I had started out in
America I would probably would have
started out whatever town I grew up and
then I would have found the next level
and then I would have gone to the next
level then I would have gone to the next
level of city that has stand-up sand up
scenes so I think I know you didn't even
ask me this question I think the big
stand-up scenes are like Minneapolis has
a big stand-ups team a lot of guys live
in Cincinnati for some unknown reason I
don't know if you know that Chicago has
always had a big you know comedy scene
but I think that's I think it's i think
the top ones are new york to new york la
Chicago those are the three top ones but
Nashville has got a big scene Atlanta
has a big scene yeah I was gonna well
you guys you guys also unless the
government ruins it you guys have a huge
film industry here which creates that
scene you know so that's why I'm still
here though is like just trying to
create my own opportunities here instead
of because I've been to New York in LA
but it seems like I would have to move
there and almost start over it's exactly
what happens so but like you said the
environment though is important in
developing around yeah you you have a
very good chance of living here of
getting something on TV and moving to
New York
Addison established an established rate
so you never are the small fish you know
I mean so when you go to LA or New York
people want and want to be around you
already whereas if you go without
anything you want to be around them yes
so and that's where I was at all times I
won't be around you guys but it's worked
out it's worked out you gotta put in the
work no matter what like if you don't if
you put in the work here and get
something you've put in the work there's
very few people that get anything
without it without putting the work in
you know I mean he's like I know guys
are like well he didn't deserve that
he put in the work he may not be your
favorite comedian but there's something
about him that he put in the work
exactly
so the repetition of stand-up and just
learning the skill set that's the
language of it and what's funny about
your style is you're you're doing almost
a different language in stand-up you've
developed like you've turned crowd work
into like its own
in its own show and not in a hacky way
oh no I don't I don't think it's I think
I think it's I honestly believe my show
is me and concentrate you know I mean
like nobody wants to be around that guy
all day but that guy that guy there you
know it's it's if you put hang in there
that's how son you know yeah and yeah
it's good but if you know you don't want
to drink the crystals yeah how what was
the process of developing that skill set
and let's get into the weeds here
because Crowder sure I think comedians
are like scared of and they may dip
their toe me like oh never mind so like
it if we could break down even just from
like a beginner all the way to now a pro
of like developing the skill set of
crowd work well first of all I think a
lot of guys are gonna I'm gonna ask this
question they're gonna say that and then
I'm gonna say this they practice crowd
work which I don't think you can
practice crowd work the only way to
practice crowd work is go to some place
and ask somebody a question and see how
they respond that's the only way you can
do it and have and I've always I've
always been that guy that's kind of just
started conversations with people in the
middle of nowhere you know even as I've
gotten older I don't talk to anybody on
a plane or anything like that
uh-huh but it takes it takes learning
conversation it takes being able to
listen to somebody to give an answer to
you know there's nothing worse when I
watch a guy do crowd work and he has the
prepared answer and hasn't heard what
they've said and it makes no sense at
all what do you do I'm a mechanic
lawyers are dicks right yeah try to
steer them into material innocence mmm
that is a technique within crowd work of
like you ask someone are you how long
you been married they're like two years
ago I've been married three years let me
tell you this and I have material about
but that's not really crowd work that's
just that's just that's just leading
into a story yeah crowd work is to me is
having a conversation having a
conversation is how long you been
married let me tell you about what yeah
that's just that's basically banter that
a band would have mmm hey Jerry how long
you been playing the bass 14 years
that's fun remember 14 years ago we
started that's that that's basically
that yeah crowd work is crowd work is
when it can go sideways and you don't
care and can still make something out of
it what is the most sideways what's the
Messiah High goes all the time like what
the last time I was here a guy was
throwing bananas at the comics before
what and then they didn't kick him out
and I went onstage it went sideways from
there they wanted to fight me like that
that kind of sideways like yeah you know
yeah it's I've had a girl pass out in
the middle of the show and hit her head
like you know I had a guy have a seizure
like that guy that the side ways where
you shouldn't you should think
everything stops but you're able to keep
it the balls moving hmm you can
concerned about them they can be taken
care of and they leave and then you keep
the show going like that kind of
sideways you know that got uh I love
when I say to somebody are you married
my husband's dead you know that kind of
thing now you got to take that and like
that goes on when people get media death
will throw a real word wrench into a
show yeah yeah so you got to be able to
you know that kind of that kind of thing
you got to be prepared for anything you
know it's like flying a plane you got to
be prepared for anything so you just and
the big thing is about making people
able to escape letting her escape from
her husband being dead if you can get
her to escape from that the rest of the
crowds gonna follow so you lean into
that once more yeah my husband's dead
you like oh what'd you go like what
happened I'm like how long uh-huh how
long has it been dead for sure you're
single all right you know right you
leave your money cuz I'll call my wife
right now and then BOOM yeah um yes I'm
stupid like that
some stupid but some stupid but
something something to make her laugh
you know you know just because yeah
people are there to laugh to escape you
know sometimes people that they're just
not there
fun at all which makes me it makes me
I'm just like mm-hmm
you've been tricked into this by your
friends and you couldn't just stay in
the car while they came in and had a
great time yeah you had to you had to
bring it down for everybody but I know
it's just having fun right the energy
you put out like if you put out a fun
energy than the audience will kind of
reflect that back to you yeah yeah yeah
and it doesn't matter if you can be the
darkest person in the comic in the world
mm-hmm if you're having fun with it have
fun like Stanhope's
he's insane but he's having fun right
right there's a reason they get on that
trip there's no way that that he doesn't
he doesn't get that if he's cranky
cranky it's not fun you know it's fun
doesn't matter you know even Marc Maron
who's the crankiest son of a [ __ ] ever
it's fun like his crankiness is fun you
know I mean and he's having fun with
being up there it's the guys that aren't
having fun up there that don't don't go
anywhere yeah you know as well teach a
class but you have like you travel like
a hundred thousand miles a year yes
through stand-up so like some shows
hello Atlanta you don't necessarily feel
like like bringing the fun energy I've
had shows I've had I where was I I was
in a bad mood I had a headache last week
mm-hmm and I drove up I and I had we had
a bunch of friends at the show and I
didn't have any place to escape or lie
down before they'd like to show that we
was in Oxnard and I live in Long Beach
and Oxnard's an hour and a half from my
house and we drove up and when I say we
my wife came along with me the show who
doesn't come to many shows but she had
friends up there I had friends up there
they're all coming out to hang out I had
I had put a Coke Zero I know this just
sounds like a pansy store I had a Coke
Zero that I'd put in the fridge like a
bottle of it that I'd put in the fridge
for the next night because it kind of
and I know it's probably if there's a
doctor watching it doesn't do anything
but in my mind a little bit of coke Zero
gives me a little bit of a pressure up
right and I'd had a headache from
driving up and
just like I was like soon as that there
I get that I have some Coke Zero and and
I get there and it's not in the fridge
no I'm just like what and the and the
waiter has thrown out the stuff out of
the fridge I'm like what it's the green
room it's my green room for the weekend
why would you throw my [ __ ] out of here
and I'll put me in such a bad mood and
then all of a sudden I knew I had to go
onstage and I'm just like I was like
okay what do we do and I just like as
you're walking up the stage things click
I'm just like yes yes yes and by the top
of the stage I was in a good mood what
do you mean things click how do you
transition into that because I've been
doing it so long I'll go but I have I
just kind of think about a couple a
couple things and I get myself to that
space okay so suddenly I mean I think
about why am I doing this because I love
this how much money am I making at the
end of the weekend I love money I mean
I'm excited because I've got my new
t-shirt to sell like I just I just like
what are you excited about not what are
you depressed about what do you bang
gree about as soon as I get a couple of
top of the stairs I'm like yes yes I'm
in show business
so you know so and then it was fun
ten years ago I probably wouldn't have
been able to do that though
ten years ago I changed everything but I
don't watch my openers so I don't know
what's going on for the show so even
though now most of the time I pick my
own openers the times that I don't pick
my openers I don't know what they've
said so nothing's made me angry which of
which I know some people are like what
does that mean you when you don't pick
your openers you can get guys that are
just they're not good they're hacky they
decided they should hit all your
premises even though they didn't the
night before like I remember I watched a
couple guys away again I can't believe
this guy's doing a bit about Canada and
I'm the one from Canada so so you know
that kind of thing so I don't know
everything's everything's fresh that's
one of the things so I don't know what's
going on I just have had you know you
you when you do have good things happen
to you
you you go bank this you Bank it in your
head and you go this was a good time so
as I'm going up the stairs I'm
remembering being in Europe and in in a
hockey arena with 10,000 people watching
I'm remembering when I got what I was on
a movie set I'm remembering when when
when when you know Martin Short told now
it's funny I'm remembering I remember
those kind of things as you as you go
along and that now you're like oh yeah
really what else happened over there
doesn't matter we're here we go let's do
this that's gold man that's gold that
mindset like we referenced at the
beginning of this it can be so even like
last night I was I wasn't like I'm
featuring this weekend in the city and
like I was just kind of just apathetic
and then I went and watched the host go
up and he was like killing and he had
good energy and I was like well Who am I
to be like your job and then I did start
to think this is your job you're lucky
to be here and that did kind of break me
out of that funk cool man so that that's
reassuring though and even a more
effective way of like thinking about
things specifically right it's not even
like this is my job it's great it's not
like how great is this what are the
great things that has happened that led
you to this well you got to remember
first of all if you're on a stage you're
you're in the top 52 right of like
there's not a there's not many jobs you
can say there's 52 weeks a year they
book 52 comedians you're in the top 52
of features at that club that year so
now you gotta memorable yeah now I'm
gonna make them forget about 51 of those
other features that's what you got I'm
gonna be number one that's great yeah
how do you feel when you were coming up
I've heard headliners be like oh don't
do any crowd were like the fury I
shouldn't do crowd work did you ever hit
those roadblocks yeah I got fired a lot
really I got fired I got fired by John
Witherspoon you didn't want to follow it
I got fired by I got fired by a camera
as a club in Texas that fired me even
when I first started headlining clubs
would fire me because I was doing crowd
work oh so yeah even if it's good yeah
they don't want you talking to the crowd
about they're like
really no you know because they have so
many guys that come in and try it I
guess mmm but I don't know it makes
sense as a feature though because like
if you set up that expectation for the
audience than when the headliner goes up
there then the audience feels like oh
this is the show nope no that was a
headliner you got to get them on on
Ralph Farris taught me this you got to
get them on to your music okay right so
it'd be like it'd be like going to see a
band and saying well the next band is
gonna play the exact same music I mean
you're gonna make them they gotta make
them love your music I guess any
comedian can find an excuse for why it
doesn't go well be honest at being them
for the most part comedians are lazy
yeah yeah lazy yeah and I don't mean
comedians sleep until 11:00 a.m. or the
kind of thing cuz I have friends I go oh
you're gonna sleep until 11:00 a yeah I
got a stage at 12:30 you tell me that
you're just gonna come down right off
and after that I'm probably will be up
until 3:30 in the morning just to let
you know mm-hmm so it doesn't it don't
don't give me that you were up at 8
o'clock but you went to bed at 11 you
pieces yet
well that sounds person you Brett Brett
you know Brett my buddy breakfast Oh how
much is late but I'm like eight hours
probably less most times and I mean I'm
back and forth across the country you
tell me if your sleep patterns not off
yeah so let's you like these they were
they were a penny you know they were
pretty penny but I invested upfront you
know I got I invested upfront and all of
this so now I've been doing this almost
four years your own water yeah that's
for you that's pontus water
it's a Georgia spring water they did
they do custom labels that's awesome
that's for you Cheers I'm not even open
I'm gonna take it I'm gonna take it home
with me
oh really I'm taking it home with me
doing me to the language yes
tell my wife I finally autographed a hot
breath Fontana
I told you it's gonna happen baby as you
like whatever
she'll be I think I'm a doctor it's all
in the suit it's all in the suit yeah
you start wearing suits I told you
they're just not for funerals so we we
veered a little bit away from crowd work
let's get back into it and help these
comics get better at crowd work oh so
they're not so happy about it
oh how first of all if you don't want to
do crowd work don't do crowd work okay
like Gaffigan does not let me open up
for him he does not like the crowd he
doesn't he's when he when it goes
sideways it goes sideways he does not
wanna he wants to he wants to tell his
story mm-hmm and it's his story gather
round right you know I mean and I and
nothing but mad respect for him but you
know that's just not the way the way I
like comedy so and it also it's not the
way I like my show I when I do stand-up
I consider the the crowd a bunch of
friends and we're hanging out and when
you're hanging out with a bunch of
friends if only one person gets to talk
you used to have a tendency to not have
many friends yeah I mean so that's the
way I look at it so this seems like the
best comedians are able to just be
conversational and it acts it is like
you're just hanging out but that's a
room of 300 yeah yeah how do you develop
that that is it a confidence thing is it
delivery like I guess I guess it's a
little bit of confidence but it's just
doing shows mmm just doing a lot and
I've done a lot of shows like even when
I first started out I when we're talking
about being addicted I you know I'm on
Amateur Night and I'm saying - the older
comedians hey there's a town called
Kamloops and has a gig and I said oh I
sear in Kamloops this week did you want
somebody just to drive with you and and
then I could do five minutes and they're
like all right like do you want money
I'm like no and they go okay then you
can come here you know I mean so yeah
you just say your stage time man that's
like a lot hour drive five hour drive
five hour drive for five minutes
for five minutes and sometimes and when
it went bad and sometimes it went good
but there's nobody nobody's up nobody's
anywhere near 70 percent even seventy
five percent good the whole you know
every time you go onstage at the
beginning of your career like it's all
about you know just getting better every
time you go onstage it goes good like
you got people like well you got a bomb
this many times no you don't have to
bomb that many times but you got a bomb
you got a bomb and you got to remember
if you don't you don't have to tape some
guys tape every show you don't have to
tape but you got to remember you got to
remember you got to remember what
happened and go oh learn from your
mistakes and then let it go don't don't
remember forever we'll just take the
pieces out of it that you need to
remember forever but the rest of the
show you let it go and never think
you're great and never think you're bad
don't read the don't read your articles
you're repressed just think you know
that was okay
I'm sustaining yeah how do you do you
remember by like reflecting on the set
when you get offstage how do you
remember just just it's in my head it's
in my head I remember the show yeah now
not as much like people say oh you
should do that I'm like when did that
happen but uh but other beginning shows
especially when you're starting out you
have a lot more time between shows like
you know when I first started out it was
maybe three or four shows a week you got
it you got a couple days in between
shows you can you can think about that
show and go and write things down mm-hmm
all this happened you know write write
this write that down and you know just
it's funny because I'm just I'm thinking
about when I started out and was like
I'm like oh yeah I know I'm thinking I'm
like oh yeah I haven't honed a comedy
book and forever when you starting out
no no but when I started out I had
notebooks I remember when I came across
the border to New York they're like what
are you doing I'm like I'm a writer I'm
going down just to write about New York
and they looked at my all these books I
mean like okay and just about you know
but yeah
that's why it about your process now is
that you don't necessarily write but
you're mindful of always taking in
information every day yes absolutely
always absorbing yeah go do the more you
do the more you'll have to talk about
hmm and I write on stage is where I
write so but the first the the seed I
have to I have to go out and do things
I'm not a guy that sits down and creates
by sitting down and writing things and I
can it's given me it's given me this
little and it's not a gift it's kind of
annoying I can watch a comic now and go
he was sitting at a desk when you wrote
that interesting yeah how can you tell I
can just see it I can just see that I
can just see the formation I'm like no
you didn't yeah you know it is one of
those things because you see an
excitement in somebody's eyes when they
talk about something that happened to
them and it's a different it's a
different even though the story may be
sold great and the show and the joke may
go over just as well it's a different
look on somebody's face when when
they're when they're and when they're
making something up but I feel like at
least starting out in comedy cuz you we
hear all these great comics and I just
write on stage and then younger comics
think they can just go up there and just
I'll just talk yeah its magic no it's
not magic but there's something to be
understood about how a joke works the
structure the that's the beginning yeah
that's what I'm saying in the beginning
yeah but I feel like when we hear people
at your level and it's like I just write
on stage and then younger people are
like oh that's all you gotta do is just
talk but there's there's you have to
understand the rules before you break
them yes just understand like the
mechanics of comedy and you can make it
your own does that make sense yeah you
agree with that yeah I did well that's
why I said I own books at the beginning
yeah okay I wrote but I always went out
and did things and then wrote about what
I did them I didn't you know I I would
try to sit down and write things but it
just like you know write a bunch of
subjects down and then write about oh I
couldn't do that now when I get jobs for
writing even
then when they want stuff I have to go
out and do stuff about what they want
and then and then write about it and
it's funny because when I do writing
all's I think about is if they don't use
these jokes I'm getting them they're
double paychecks right of course
comedian always hoarding joke yeah cuz
I'll ask so you're not gonna use that
like no mm-hmm can I use it
yeah like okay when you when you were
seven at one time yeah yeah it was a
really had to write Gabriel Gabriel
glaces had a show stand-up revolution I
think was called and they hired me to
write a bunch of intros and extras and
jokes and stuff for when he was on stage
and somebody there play they missed the
plane and they weren't gonna make it to
film the show and they're like Ian go do
it and I'm like okay I said okay I said
you know those jokes I had and he's like
yeah I said do you mind if I do them
he's like go ahead so I went and did all
these jokes and then after which goes oh
they're really good so I did a whole set
with just these jokes that I'd written
for Kate and it went well well it's
great I still use a couple of them oh so
you will use jokes I I mean we've them
and well yeah you know there's there's
there's times where it lulls so now I
just I just go into I'll go into jokes
and then something will happen back in
the conversation mm-hmm-hmm blow into
jokes you know it's it's it's it's like
it's like surfing you got to catch the
waves and figure out and you know how to
not get tumbled into the sand yeah and
there's a big self-awareness I feel like
when it comes on stage in learning
what's working for you on there and then
just doubling down on that for example
like I have found with my comedy very
recently that sarcasm plays well and
when I do I'll get laughs on facial
expressions mm-hmm
so I mean I'm in the infant stages of
even learning how to manipulate that but
I've started to notice I can they
elongate a laugh by facial expressions
it's like when you were developing crowd
worker your stage persona where there
where they're almost little little
breadcrumbs that you've started to kind
of put into your toolkit of like okay I
know I can execute this tool here and
over here if that happens I know I can
react like this and it's me and not just
a caricature yeah I guess I was like
like yeah man I have noises that come
out of me like and I know different
stuff that comes out of me that didn't
come out of me when I was first starting
out I was very deadpan like when I had a
conversation with the crowd I was
deadpan I would didn't I didn't move I
still don't take the microphone out of
the stand very much but I was completely
my just stiff on stage and and I you
know I used to hang out with Hedberg
when I first started out oh my gosh and
we used to go do all these shows all
over the place and we both had long hair
and we were both deadpan he was more I
had a bunch of one-liner jokes and he
had all these one-liner jokes and we
kind of hung out a little bit so we used
to come stay at my house all the time
and then oh you know it's funny is he
married a girl that was at my my very
first open mic Lynn was at my very first
open mic and then I seen it she was she
was hanging out and Bonnie McFarlane was
at my very first open mic and and you
know and Lynn was hanging out and she
was kind of doing stand-up and kind of
not doing stand-up and then and then I
seen her in Toronto and she'd been hit
by a car
I'm the nice in Toronto again she'd been
hit by another car I'm like Lynn you've
been hit by two cars and she's like yeah
I'm like you gotta look both ways look
one way one way don't it so anyway and
then the next time I see her she's like
she was one man I'm like what are you
open up for me she's married to him I'm
like what and then next thing I know
he's dead like I blame her and he died
on April Fool's Day and I never believed
it nobody thought it was fake he was one
of my favorites and like it when I heard
yeah he died I was like that's April
Fool's Day there's no way that's perfect
Mitch Hedberg
and then no drugs drugs drugs drugs
drugs and just so funny do you have a
favorite like Mitch Hedberg story or an
experience you could share I have a lot
I just my big thing that I don't know
the last time I seen him he was really
healthy and that's that's the way I want
to remember him mm-hmm
it was like I was like he was happy he
was it was good and you know we had a
conversation and we hadn't we hadn't had
a conversation a long time he was it was
just a mess so I was just like on foot
he's doing really well and then he was
to add a couple months later and I was
like well that was confusing so I
actually I like to remember remember him
and and I just think of them as I can
remember I can see the green room that
we're in in Montreal we're in Montreal
and we're having a I can it's a I think
it's an underground but it's you know
it's like on this brick room and it's
like old those old like stone bricks and
you know who else is in the room but
they're kind of [ __ ] on the other side
where the flight of the conchords wrong
yeah and I just remember talking with my
age and stuff and he was really healthy
that's what I remember about it yeah
when we think about an on stage persona
versus offstage how how similar were the
two personality pretty much pretty much
yeah okay yeah you know I just think of
him like you know that that smile and
laugh that he did on stage it was smile
and laugh he did off stage that's you
know you know it was nice to make him
laugh so and he was more of a pen to
paper guy yeah but it was out there man
it was it wasn't it wasn't sit down and
write down there was hey you know those
were his thoughts those were real
thoughts that that was that wasn't that
wasn't pushing for a joke that just came
out naturally you know which I love I
love unforced humor and he was not
forced at all you know I mean how early
into your career did you guys connect
um I was still living in Vancouver Oh's
before he moved to New York
Oh from the beginning oh my god I want
to say 93 I want to say 93 and you know
who else was around and and he only told
me a couple years ago cuz I thought I'd
met him in New York when I first met him
was Brody Stephens was hanging around
Vancouver Wow so yeah I don't know what
my eyes are starting to tear up just
thinking about that uh I don't know why
I don't even know either of them but you
I guess when you're in like the comedy
world well so connected to the your
peers in a sense even if you didn't know
them yeah I see what you're saying yeah
it's it's a pretty small world are the
staff it's grown a lot but it's still
pretty small it's when when you hear a
name and you don't know who it is and
stand-up you're like well that's
interesting like I'd never heard of
Kevin Hart before and then all of a
sudden he was a star Wow you know
apparently we floated in the same world
but I never so it's very there's a very
few of those people
hmm well what a skill set a lot of the
best comedians have is being able to
make the audience see what you're
talking about
like wait waiting picture yeah painting
of the best Cosby was the best at
painting a picture yep for sure
yeah you know I just before the incident
I saw him live here one of the craziest
common nights of my life I saw Cosby at
one venue and then went and watched
Chappelle at another Cosby did like two
hours and it was like it was just
instant I didn't look at my watch once
it you're just in his movie the entire
time yeah I don't mean to cut you off
oh that's fine I just I'm thinking about
the best night I had for stand-up was
seeing Sam Kinison hmm and then I seen
Drake say they're the same night I don't
know you should look you should look him
up okay
he's written he wrote a ton of movies
but he was such a funny stand-up I
remember some of his jokes were just
like
he was hot he was on the People's Court
once because him and his wife are going
through a divorce and he threw a through
a baby carriage at home why a role model
it means like I didn't throw it I rolled
it at her really fast it was one but he
was dead penny he looked like yeah he
did look like a rockstar
this tall thin guy was like shaggy hair
and I remember he was he talked about
watching uh the Ronald McDonald House
telethon and he they got to a million
dollars and Ozzie could think was how
big of a house is this [ __ ] clown
need one of his other ones well my
doctor told me to quit smoking but I
know if I quit smoking I will go right
back to air when Oh God or sucking dick
was a second dicker hair I can't
remember one of those do bleep just it
was just he's just so [ __ ] it was
dark he's so dark
yeah look him up the Drake say there
Drake say there okay yeah there's got to
be YouTube stuff out there he did like
an HBO special and I think it was on
young comedians special at one point you
remember he wrote it maybe he wrote meet
the parents I can't remember something
like you wrote a couple movies so we all
have homework
y'all have home or say there Drake say
there when we talk about being able to
make the audience see what you're
talking about
mm-hmm what is what is like the
technique or a connection connection as
soon as you get the connection with the
audience okay I'll see what you want how
do you establish that connection to work
you have to do bro I almost think you're
holding it you're like holding the
negative Sorcerer's Stone over here like
the Lord of the Rings I'm not giving you
the real I'm a little bit like that I'm
a little over people ask me mine you
gotta learn bro you got it
when I say it's a personal journey I'm
serious mm-hmm there's nothing you can
maybe get a couple a couple things out
of this but there's nothing that you can
do by watching
without going and doing it right you
gotta do it there's you gotta you gotta
you gotta it's it's like boxing you you
might think you're the best shadowbox or
ever but tell you get punched in the
face you don't know how you were gonna
respond in any sort of situation so you
got to get on stage and you got to get
on stage
everywhere you got you got you got to do
a wedding you got to do a baby shower
you got to do a bar you got to do a
laundromat you got to do you got to do a
coffee shop you got to do everything you
got to do colleges you got to do a
college college cafeteria on top of a
table while people just want their
dinner and on some other people want to
watch the so proper that's on the TV
behind you that's different now because
everybody has phones you gotta you know
I mean you got it you gotta do stand-up
in places where they're not expecting
you you got to do stand-up in places
where they don't want you to be mmm you
got a deuced and you got to learn how to
how to win people over you got to learn
how to make people go or who the [ __ ] is
this and by the end of it how do we not
hear about him before that's you got to
do all that like it's it's great when
you do a show and everybody knows you
that's [ __ ] simple well that's simple
when they know when you have a crowd and
they know what you're all about and
they're there to see you that is so easy
when you're starting out and even now
even now I do shows where nobody knows
who I am
got it you got to do a corporate where
there's there's limits on what you can
say you got it you got to be put in a
box and you got to figure out how to
paint inside the lines and still be
funny because my I'm in my show I'm
nowhere near the lines right so you got
to be able to you got to be able to do
what everything and when I say I can say
things I can say this but unless you go
do it doesn't it really means fuck-all
that that's why I do this show is
because it is like a tan bag cranky old
man but me that is the thing about just
information and like this this Park has
a wealth of information for comedians
but it is like unless you don't go do it
and yeah it's it goes on deaf ears
mm-hmm but my my goal so many people are
trying to do comedy now if there's a way
to help comics suck less at comedy cuz I
love Commons that suck suck there's no
hope you don't think no there's a
there's there's certain levels of suck
you know there's the funny guy that that
there's the funny guy that can't figure
out how to get across the bridge to the
crowd and you're like once that guy
figures out how to use a bridge he's
gonna be really good
Tom state Tom states another guy you can
look at home state tom state he's in
he's in he lives in Scotland now when we
started out together he was [ __ ] he
was so funny but [ __ ] bombed and was
not funny on stage but he was the
funniest guy I'd met offstage you know I
mean like just so funny and he would
bomb and bomb a bomb and then all of a
sudden just one day he figured it out
and he's he's he's huge in Europe he
found his kids his his his crowd and he
lives in Europe now and he just he's
funny when he's over here but his crowds
and he's decided to make his his
livelihood in Europe and he's [ __ ]
he's so funny because he he did it and
did it and figure it out how to get
across the bridge there's other guys
that aren't funny on stage and aren't
funny off stage I have no idea why
they're there but they're addicted to it
so I'm just like do yourself yeah but
you're always gonna be on open mic I'm
never gonna see you get off a little
open mic you know that kind of thing and
then there's guys that are funny onstage
that have figured out the formula but
have never made anybody laugh offstage
so you gotta you gotta look at things
and go how who's what
right yeah cuz there's there's a lot of
Emperor's with no clothes on in this
business it's like you've met quite a
few of them I'm not saying anything you
know who you are it's so it's almost
like for the connection if you're
connected to what you're talking about
then the audience will connect with it
as opposed to you trying to reach to the
audience to connect you have to connect
with your material first and then
that'll translate through connect yeah
yeah I feel like if you push okay you
push people away
if you if you it's funny that we're
talking about connection and I can't get
this across if if it's kind of hacky but
if you build it they will come
so I think that's the movie but if you
build the scenario and you build it
build it up in your head and it's funny
because I'm thinking about my show right
now I'm like I really don't know how my
show starts like and I'm trying to tell
comedians how to [ __ ] do things right
now but no you got to figure out how how
to make them feel comfortable first
right no and then you gotta let them get
on your wavelength like however you do
stand-up and then you gotta have the
right words to describe what's coming
out of your head that's how you connect
you can call [ __ ] on me I know
there's a couple of you're gonna be four
I can write in all over his thinking
this guy's speech yet no one's doing no
one's doing that I guarantee you it's
golden I'm talking to you but it's just
uh you know gotta get out there and do
it yeah I mean your connections
different than my connection mm-hmm yes
so the the final thing here I think we
connected on that that was good I give
anything tonight it's funny the most
nervous breakdowns I've ever had is
describing how to do comedy I did the
show called the history of the joke for
the History Channel and and I was one of
the people they talked to and you can
see me have a meltdown when I have to
describe how I'm funny cuz I'm like I
just don't think about it I don't think
about I just did just I'd do it hmm
so I don't know when I have more I'm
thinking about I'm like well you do this
and then you do this and I'm like oh
I've just built a pentagram yeah yeah
I'm fantastic there's a
everyone has a different we all have the
same destination but it's how you get
there is uniquely yours right but I
there are techniques and concepts which
you did share which can help
comedians find their own unique path
right yeah you gave them a machete to
start cutting their own path yeah just
just enjoy it yeah and I like wonder how
people say well you know you're busy
building your crowd and then the guy
I'll get that in his head it goes well I
was only trying to make a certain amount
of people laugh mmm like no yeah you
know like it's it's ok well it's ok if
you do something and only a certain
group get it but we want the whole crowd
to laugh where that's that's everybody's
goal is for to have the crowd laugh not
four or five people in the room well
early on didn't you have trouble with
you would only make the back of the room
laugh and not the audience like I heard
you say that yeah I was during I was
jury that was during uh yeah I was
pretty good at playing through the
comics and was given [ __ ] for it quite a
few times one time I was on a tour for
just for laughs with Dane Cook Jim
Breuer Alonzo Bodden and one other guy
who I can't remember who it was but I
was having to follow Dane and this is
right when Dane was becoming Dane Lang
it was it was fire it was yeah fire and
I don't mind I don't mind following
anybody when I was going down like like
people people were just like what would
you see you know that something's going
on they know like there's there's and
then and now he in back and I go there
and I'm just tanking and the guys the
guys that I'm on the tour worth are just
[ __ ] laughing at me and the producer
of the show thinks that I'm doing it on
purpose I was like are you [ __ ]
serious like I it's the worst it's the
producers are the best and the worst
people they're great because they want
to put on shows
they [ __ ] know nothing about comedy
and they're yip-yap and what they took
the advice they give people is [ __ ]
[ __ ] for 99% of the time it's just
like well this person did that well I'm
not that person
you know if they'd come up to me gonna
are you having fun I'm black I would
have been honest I said can I go on in
front of Dane cuz [ __ ] something's
going on with Dane then I can't explain
it you know I'm seeing lightning
captured in a [ __ ] bottle right now
and you guys are like letting me go up
and pretend I'm a [ __ ] butterfly you
know it was just it was just so annoying
and they didn't you know and they think
they all we know who the next star is
gonna be well they just picked a bunch
of us that they thought we're gonna do
very well mhm and and one guy was
becoming a star so did you switch in the
lineup no I had to [ __ ] bomb the
whole tour the whole tour you bomb 11
shows just [ __ ] remember I think I
did well in Vancouver or something like
that it was just I'm a hometown hero
I had buddy out and I think we got drunk
and I just went on stage it was it was
fun so what is what is a common trait
you you mean literally you're around the
1% of comedians like is there a common
trait or a discipline or an attribute
that comedians that excel to that level
have work ethic mostly like okay yeah
it's it's uh it's going back to Gary Vee
it's it's and and I love him and people
are like what's Gary Vee it's just you
know it's a crazy internet guy that
talks about things and he has a belief
in putting in the work and that is and I
think I'm along with those guys I gave
up all my Saturday nights I cancelled a
lot of things mm-hm I loved a lot of you
know I I wouldn't want to be married to
anybody but my wife but I didn't meet my
wife until much later in my career when
I could actually put something into a
relationship you know like you gay it's
it's finding somebody while you're going
through that is is very difficult you
know it's it didn't they they did very
like some of the guys that I know got
married early and I don't know how they
found those women like I don't I don't
know how you find somebody in your life
where you go I'm in love with you but I
have a mistress and she's more important
you and her name is comedy and I will go
see her and lie to you about going to
see her I mean I know exactly what you
mean and to find somebody that goes okay
yeah all right before my joy seeing you
with mistress you haven't been the
mistress in a while well that's how it
is now for me for me I've come home more
than two weeks my wife is like probably
go see if I can [ __ ] comedy but it's a
legit lifestyle that people who want to
pursue it it is a lifestyle it is it is
the best and the worst mmm yeah heroin
it changes like your schedule changes
[ __ ] rapidly there's nothing you know
yeah
always on call someone calls me like I
have a $75 gig in town if you want to do
it can you be here in 30 minutes yeah
yeah oh sorry honey I got a cancel
dinner yeah go make $75 yes no no now I
get those calls and I'm just like so
what number am i like what how many
other people do you [ __ ] call before
you call me I got a couple guys hey gosh
I got a guy a guy good to send me an
email hey you want to be part of the
show down at the store on on Sunday I'm
like [ __ ] off it's Thursday you didn't
just book this
bite my dick you know what I thought we
were better not bitter no in certain
times certain times I Melania I said I
say that I'm better but I'll tell people
to [ __ ] off no you know I'm saying like
just now I want more of a life right so
now I go out and do things other than
then stand up and I can tell you right
now if my wife heard that you go
[ __ ] but guess what Monday Tuesday's
are her now and it didn't used to be
that when I was doing comedy [ __ ] it
was seven days a week I was going out
doing sets then going and doing open
mics I'd I'd [ __ ] you know up until
about 10 years ago I was still doing
four or five open mics a week and how
long into your career was that how many
years ten years ago so about up to about
ten years in your career you were still
18 years four or five open mics a week
yeah and then you just all of a sudden
you go oh you know what guys really fun
but I can't be associated with you guys
anymore and it's it's it's all of a
sudden becomes quality over quantity you
know like me being on a [ __ ] bar
gig doesn't get me any better for being
in front of 300 to 10,000 people
yes you know so but this is 10 15 years
in the game listeners need to understand
this isn't him being like I don't feel
like it this is him like I've been
forging the sword in this environment
close that door so new ones can open yes
I just want that perspective for
comedians that yes know where it's
coming from
this isn't someone who didn't feel like
there's someone who earned it the hard
way and then was like okay now I've
earned the right to say no to this bar
gig yeah yeah yes and then and then find
something else that you're not good at
and you're learning like like I do my
podcast and I'm learning from that every
time I do it you know a lot of work it's
a lot of work on casting a lot of work
well you know what it's cheating you do
if you ever get a TV show it's teaching
you too
be able to be a producer mm-hmm I mean
yeah so I didn't think about that
it's everything that we do in in in in
our industry the beginning is college
you know I mean it's your college years
mm-hmm and then the next step is trying
to put that business together and then
the next step after that is being able
to run the business so the guys that
don't do the college years are very
noticeable though yeah I earn it yeah
so we touched on this at the beginning
the final thing I just i would be
remissed because you're the master of
this craft of crowd work you guys can't
have it you know it's my poem I think
you just got to do it a lot and then
you'll get better at it but like when
you started out was it just you would
just ask like how did you develop this
into it becomes like an hour show I
think it's just curiosity that's all
it's all as my show is based on
curiosity okay I asked these questions
when I sit down and talk to somebody I
you know it's it's it's not always the
same question but I ask and I want to
hear your answer and that's all as a
show is listening listening asking
having a great time laughing and I think
it's valuable that you said these are
questions you would ask offstage yes
that when you're on stage you just ask
them the answers
people got cookies here there's cookies
in this hotel lobby
so before we that guy said he was a
comedian by the way as well what's
happening she just laughed she'd just
drop her cooking on the floor she put it
back in there nobody cookie back just
put it back in there just put the coach
back there's a garbage right there I
think we right on an odd cast you
hilarious
yeah the guy that works here was talking
as we're setting up he's a comedian he's
like no that's funny there's so many
people that say yes so much but I think
the valuable lesson from this interview
is you have to do it yet period just do
it and you will learn as you do when you
do it there's further first for the
first five I know people like 5 5 10
years you got a you if you're sitting at
home watching TV you're failing um I did
not see one Seinfeld until they came on
to repeats because I was never home on a
Thursday night
so that's the way comedy he's got to be
for you you gotta be if you're if you're
at home view if you a fear for if you're
at home between the hours of 7:00 and
10:00 you're [ __ ] you're cheating
yourself because you gotta you just got
to get out there and do it all right hot
breath averse what you just experienced
is a crash course in the reality of
comedy and that is doing the work well
through no your we're just doing the
outro you're good or miss hotel lobby
and doing the work includes meeting
people in hotel lobbies and doing
podcasts but at the end of the day all
this Carlton every it is it is the Ritz
Carlton of the same rings so all these
techniques you've learned all these
insights you've learned at the end of
the day if you don't work at them
they're going to be jus
let's to you so if anything you've
learned from this interview put in the
work no excuses no next time if you want
to do comedy you have to do it period
and this is a comedy professional sports
problem you got a you got a you got to
work your ass off here and you know
here's the other thing the same as
professional sports and I'm sorry to
interrupt you know no play have fun have
fun have fun yeah if it's not fun you're
Don bro have fun doing the work have fun
doing the work it's when we say work the
work is just getting off your butt yeah
being onstage you gonna say work yeah
the work later on in life is getting
onto the plane you know
that's the work is is making yourself do
something though being onstage is if
you're not getting off on that if being
on stage is actually work you're not
you're not for comedy but you are good
to still listen if you want to listen
you're not easily take my days they
don't listeners no no hey come and go as
you please all I know is in all these
episodes we just learn a lot and this we
learned thanks button from a mask for
asking me dude I'm a fan I've been a fan
I wish I could have come to the shows
are you lonely are you in the festival
or something is there there's a I'm
going there is the Laughing Skull
Festival but I'm just booked at a club
this week which Claire Atlanta comedy
theater it's a North it's north of the
city a little bit uh-huh we have cities
I mean we have clubs like downtown here
north of the city salad okay all in
competition with each other they're all
like different demographics like they're
all in different areas and they cater to
a different audience so it's it's
Atlanta is good like that to develop as
well because you can perform in front of
a diverse amount of people and what's
good yeah I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm
glad I'm performing in the land again I
like it here a lot so oh well we like
you here thank you
so sweetie if you did enjoy this episode
please first off the best way you can
support the show reach out to Ian let
him know how much you enjoyed this what
was your favorite part or not
favorite part but just connect connect
with them let them know that you found
this valuable so he'll come back on here
and share even more secrets that he's
hesitant to share but it's hot breath
podcast comm is the website the YouTube
page of course hot breath pod Joel
buyers comedy comm is my website where
you can read my blog I also have other
exciting content on there but at the end
of day it's all about just getting
better at comedy and this gentleman here
helped us do that today please let them
know where they can find you and all
that can find me on Ian's bag calm and
then it'll take you to all my social
medias Ian bagg Ian bagg at Instagram in
bag comedy Facebook you know it'll take
you to all them so please and listen to
my podcast Ian bagg bought a house all
about me Ian bagg doing stand-up and it
bought me a house so if this could be a
final activity could you could you look
into the camera and tell people why they
should listen to the hot breath podcast
guys cuz I'm on it that's why you should
listen to this who's on damn show me Ian
bagg on the hot breath comedy show no
podcast podcast hot breath oh my god
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen you should listen
to hot breath comedy because it is the
best thing to learn about comedy going
deep into how the sausages are made boom
Ian bang breath yeah that's great comedy
sausage breath comedy sausage that's
what I will thanks being on hot breath
Ian thanks for having me on your Black
Panther Party show
I breath